SPEAKER: Vision API can be
used to extract information
from images, such as labels,
text, landmarks, and more.
Let's see how to use
Vision API with C#.
First, make sure Vision API
is enabled in your project
and a service account
exists to make API calls.
Both are explained in the
code lab in the video notes.
In Cloud Shell, let's create a
simple .NET console app and add
Vision API Nougat
package to the project.
Open the online code editor
and navigate to program.cs.
We will perform text
detection on this image.
First, reference
Vision API library
and create an image
annotator client.
Point to the image and
call DetectText method
and print out the text.
Now run the app.
There you go.
You just performed text
detection using the Vision API.